with me now in the studio is richard
walker our chief
international editor nice to see you
richard um fond du lion is expected to
give a a a speech now
at a time when the european union is
fragile we could say that certainly
and uh one main goal is to reassure the
black citizens that
she has a a solid pandemic recovery plan
what could it look like
yeah well the center piece of this brine
is the eu's recovery fund which
alexandra just mentioned a lot earlier
at the top of the show which
for fondue line this is really pretty
much chalked up as her biggest
achievement so far
in her you know less than a year in
office now
this fund um is uh something that's
already been agreed it was agreed back
in july at a summit between uh all of
the eu leaders
uh after much haggling and it really is
seen as something of a breakthrough and
that's a breakthrough in two ways first
of all
in in the eu coming together and
deciding to really kind of spend its way
out of a crisis like this
but also in the way that the money is
being raised a
real kind of sign of solidarity among
member states
where member states have agreed that the
european commission is going to go out
and borrow this money themselves on the
market
and that will be underpinned by all of
the member states that money will be
guaranteed by all of the member states
this is something that hasn't happened
before
so i think she will be presenting that
as something like the european union
came together
look to the future when dealing with the
economic fallout from
the pandemic and now it's time to look
to the future and think about what are
we going to do with that fund there is
still
some resistance though to taking on this
level of debt to the collective debt
is it a done deal that every nation is
behind this right now
yeah i mean it was a it was a it was a a
hard slog to get to that deal but that
deal now stands and it was certainly
unpopular with some of the
smaller uh sort of uh northern european
states is the shorthand for them states
that
that prefer not to borrow too much money
but they did sign up to this
um and i think yeah fond du lion's
message is probably going to be
okay it's time to look to the future and
i think key for her is going to be
marrying
this effort to kind of get the economy
going with
the priorities that the commission
already had for the european union
things like
tackling climate change okay now along
with um
tackling climate change and the
chronovirus recovery we have migration
that's shaped up to be a very big issue
over the last week of course with the
fire at the moria
uh migration camp on lesbos that's the
eu's biggest
migration camp migrant camp 12 000
people now
homeless how could the plan that we
might see being put forward today differ
from what we have right now
yeah well i mean it is really striking
isn't it how something like migration
that has been on the back burner for a
long time you know there was a real
there was an intense crisis in 2015 but
it's kind of slipped back down the
agenda
it takes an event like this uh like this
fire to
whack it back to the top of the agenda
now the migration pact
that the eu has talked about for a long
time
was something that looked like it was
going to be shunted off again
eclipsed by the pandemic but here we've
seen it really come back onto the agenda
now uh the plan was due to be announced
on the 30th of september they've now
pulled that back
a week to next week uh usually underline
we'll be talking about it today but we
don't expect her to go into detail
but the the challenge i mean the reason
that they've never managed to get
through to
an agreement on this is that it is such
a difficult topic
migration is one of the politically
hottest potatoes that europe faces
um and the kind of the key not to crack
and there's very little consensus still
on the issue when you look at hungary
poland exactly um the czech republic
we're getting live pictures right now
and
uh i believe that that is a fun line
right there the commission president
just sat down with the pink top
um waiting for her we're expecting to
hear first from the eu
parliament president uh david sasoli
he's an italian
parliamentarian there he is uh right now
he's addressing
the parliament first so he'll be making
some initial comments and
and opening the session um after that
we'll be
hearing from fond du lion um
richard in terms of in terms of
migration um
when we look at this issue you said it
was on the back burner it's very much
front and center after this fire
um it it has as well as you know taking
on all this debt but another issue
that's made the
european union so fragile in terms of
developing a common uh policy
what are the big sticking points moving
forward with migration regardless of
what we hear from
online well i think that the the this
tough nut that they've failed to crack
so far
is is what really the you know
supporters of some
eu-wide migration pact really want which
is basically a kind of
uh protocol for distributing refugees
among eu member states according to the
size of their economy and the size of
their population
now particularly the central and eastern
european countries what
this group called the visha grad 4 are
opposed to that
they say that they don't want to be
taking in large amounts of migrant
now the question is can the commission
come up with some kind of plan
that gets them on board either
persuading them
uh to say to say all right we will uh
sign up to that something or kind of
coming up with some other solution and
this is something that has been hinted
at in the past
okay we'll see if that comes up we're
going to go to the speech
right now in brussels from the
commission
six president europeans have really
shown
this strength of spirit we have seen
this
with the care workers who moved into
care homes
to look after those who were ill and
elderly we saw this with the doctors and
nurses
who became family members
for those who were breathing their last
breaths
the frontline workers who
day and night week after week
took risks so we didn't have to
their empathy their courage and their
sense of duty is an inspiration to us
all and i would like to begin this
speech by paying tribute to them
[Applause]
their stories also reveal a lot a lot
about the state of our world and
the state of our union they show the
power of humanity
and the sense of mourning which will
live long in our society
and they expose to us
the fragility all around us
a virus a thousand times smaller than a
grain of sand
exposed how delicate life can be
it laid bare the strains on our health
systems
and the limits of a model that values
wealth above well-being
it brought into sharper focus the
planetary fragility
that we see every day through melting
glaciers
burning forests and now through global
pandemics
it changed the way we behave and
communicate
keeping our arms at length and our faces
behind
masks it showed us just
how fragile our community of values
really is and how quickly it can be
called into questions
around the world and even here in our
union
but people want to move out of this
corona world
out of this fragility out of this
uncertainty they are ready for change
and they are ready to move on and this
is the moment for europe the moment
for europe to lead the way from this
fragility
towards a new vitality and that
is what i want to talk about today
honorable members
i say this because in the last month
we have rediscovered the value of what
we hold in common
as individuals we have all sacrificed
a piece of our personal liberty for the
safety of others
and as a union we all shared
a part of our sovereignty for the common
good
we turned fear and division between
member states
into confidence in our union we show
that it is possible and what is possible
when we trust each other and we trust
the european institutions
and with all of that we choose to not
only repair and recover for the here and
now
but to shape a better world a better way
of living
for the world of tomorrow and this is
next generation eu this is our
opportunity to make change happen
by design and not by disaster
or by dictate from others in the world
to emerge stronger by creating
opportunities
for the world of tomorrow and not just
building contingency
contingencies for the world of yesterday
we have everything we need to make this
happen
we have shaken off the old excuses and
home comforts
we have the vision we have a plan
we have the investment it is now time to
get
to work this morning
i've sent a letter of intent to
president sasali
and chancellor merkel on behalf of the
german presidency
outlining the commission's plan for the
year ahead
i will not present every initiative
today
but i want to touch on what our union
must
focus on in the next 12 months
honorable members the people of europe
are still suffering
it is a period of profound anxiety for
millions
who are concerned about the health of
their families
the future of their jobs or simply
getting through till the end of the
month
the pandemic and the uncertainty that
goes with it
is not over and the recovery is still in
its early stage so our
first priority is to pull each other
through this
and to be there for those that need it
and thanks to our unique social market
economy
europe can do just that
it is above all a human economy
that protects us against the great risks
of
life illness
ill fortune unemployment
and poverty it offers stability
and helps us better absorb shocks
it creates opportunities and prosperity
by promoting
innovation growth and fair competition
never before has that enduring promise
of protection stability and opportunity
being more important than it is today
allow me to explain why
first europe must continue to protect
lives and livelihoods
this is all the more important in the
middle of a pandemic that shows
no sign of running out of steam or
intensity
we know how quickly numbers can spiral
out of control
so we must continue to handle this
pandemic pandemic
with extreme care responsibility and
unity
in the last six months our health
systems
and workers have produced miracles
every country has worked to do its best
for its citizens
and europe has done more together
than ever before when the member states
closed
borders we created green lanes for goods
when more than 600 000 european citizens
were stranded all over the world the eu
brought them back home
when some countries introduced export
bans
for critical medical goods we stopped
that
and ensured that critical medical goods
should go
where it was needed we worked with the
european industry to increase the
production of masks of gloves
of tests of ventilators our civil
protection mechanism ensured
that doctors from romania could treat
patients in italy
or that latvia could send mosques to his
baltic's neighbors
and we achieved all that without
having full competencies so for me
it is crystal clear we need to build
a stronger european health union
it is time to do that
and to start making this a reality we
must now draw the first lessons from the
health crisis
we need to make our new e4 eu for health
program
future proof and this is why i had
proposed to increase
funding and i'm grateful that this
parliament
is ready to fight for more funding
and remedy the cuts made by the european
council
and we need to strengthen our crisis
preparedness and management
of cross-border health issues
as a first step we will propose to
reinforce
and empower the european medicines
agency and ecdc our center for disease
prevention and control
as a second step we will
build a european barda
an agency for biomedical advanced
resource research and development
this new agency will support our
capacity and readiness
to respond to cross-border threats and
emergencies
whether of natural or deliberate origin
we need strategic stockpiling
to address supply chain dependencies
notably for pharmaceutical goods
and as a third step it is clearer than
ever that we must discuss
the question of health competencies
and i think it is a noble and urgent
task
to do this for the conference on the
future
of europe
and finally and because it was a global
crisis
we need to learn the global lessons
this is why along with prime minister
conte
and the italian g20 presidency next year
i will convene a global health summit
next year in italy this will show
europeans
that our union is there to protect them
all
and this is exactly what we have done
when it comes to workers
when i took office i vote to create an
instrument
to protect workers and businesses
from external shocks because i knew from
my experience as a minister for labor
and social affairs
that these schemes work they keep people
in
jobs they keep the skills in the
companies and of course they keep the
business the smes in business
these smes are the motor of our economy
and they will be the engine of our
recovery
and this is why the commission created
the sure program
and i want to thank this house
for working on it in record time
if europe has so far avoided mars
unemployment
seen elsewhere it is thanks in large
part
to the fact that around 40
million people applied for short time
work schemes
the speed and the unity of purpose means
that 16 countries will soon receive
almost
90 billion euros from sure
to support workers and companies from
lithuania
to spain it will give peace of mind
to families who need that income to
put food on the table or to pay the rent
and it will help protect millions of
jobs incomes and companies
right across our union this is
real european solidarity
in action and it reflects
the fact that in our union the dignity
of
work must be sacred
but the truth is that for too many
people
work no longer pays
dumping wages destroys the dignity of
work
penalizes the entrepreneur who pays
decent wages
and distorts fair competition in the
single market and this has to stop
and this is why the commission will put
forward a legal proposal
to support member states to set up a
framework for minimum wages
everyone must have access
everyone must have access to minimum
wages
either through collective bargaining
or through statutory minimum wages
i personally i am a strong advocate of
collective bargaining
and the proposal will fully respect
national competences and traditions
we have seen in many web member states
that introduced
collectively bargained minimum wages
how a well-negotiated minimum wage
secures jobs and creates
fairness both for the workers and for
the companies who
really value them so honorable members
minimum wages work and it is time
that work paid
the second promise of the social market
economy is that of
stability
by showing it was united and up to the
task
europe provided the stability that our
economies need
i will not forget when the crisis hit
the commission immediately triggered the
general escape clause for the very first
time in our history
we flexibilized our european funds and
state aid rules
authorizing more than 3 trillion euro in
support to companies and industry
from fishermen in croatia to farmers in
greece
from smes in italy to freelancers in
denmark
the european central bank took decisive
action through the pep
program the commission proposed next
generation eu
in record time thus combining
investment and the much much needed
reforms
the council endorsed it in record time
this house is working towards
voting on it with maximum speed
honorable members for the first time
and for exceptional times europe has
put in place its own common tools
to complement national fiscal
stabilizers
this is a remarkable moment of unity in
the european union
and this is an achievement we should
take collective
pride in we made that
[Applause]
now it's time to hold our course
we have all seen the forecasts
we can expect our economies to start
moving again after
a 12 drop in gdp in the second quarter
but as the virus lingers
so does the uncertainty here in europe
and around the world
so this is definitely not the time
to withdraw support our economies need
continued policy support and the
delicate balance will need to be struck
between providing financial support
and ensuring fiscal sustainability
in the longer term there is no greater
way to stability
and competitiveness than through a
stronger
economic and monetary union
confidence in the euro has never been
stronger
the historic agreement on next
generation eu
shows the political backing that it has
and we must now use this opportunity
to make structural reforms in our
economies and
complete the capital markets union and
the banking union
deep and liquid capital markets are
essential to give
businesses access to the finance they
need
and they needed to grow and invest in
recovery and in the future
and they are also a prerequisite to
further strengthen
the international role of the euro so
let's get to work
and finally complete this generational
project
and the third enduring promise is
the promise of opportunity
the pandemic reminded us of many things
we have
may have forgotten or we may have taken
for granted
we were reminded how linked our
economies are
and how crucial a fully functioning
simple market
is to our prosperity and to the way we
do things
the single market is all about
opportunity
opportunity for consumers to get value
for money
opportunities for a company to sell
everywhere in europe
and opportunities for the industry to go
to drive
global competitiveness and for all of us
it is about the opportunity
to make the most of the freedoms we
cherish as europeans
it gives our companies the scale they
need to prosper
and to save heaven for them in times of
troubles
we rely on it every day to make our
lives easier
and it is crucial for managing the
crisis and recovering our strength
so let's give it a boost
we must tear down the barriers of the
single market
we must cut red tape we must step
up implementation and enforcement and we
must
restore the four freedoms in full and as
fast as
possible the linchpin of this is a fully
functioning schengen area of
free movement and we will work
with parliament and member states
to bring this high up on our political
agenda
and we will propose a new strategy
for the future of schengen
based on this strong internal market
the european industry has long powered
our economy
providing a stable living for millions
and creating the social hubs around
which our communities
are built we presented
a new industry strategy in march
to ensure industry could lead the trin
green and digital transition
the last six months have only
accelerated that transformation
at a time when the global competitive
landscape is fundamentally
changing as to
we have to keep up and this is why
we will update our industry strategy
in the first half of next year and
adapt our com competition framework
which should also keep pace
honorable members all this
will ensure europe gets back on its feet
but as we pull through together we must
also propel ourselves forward
in the world of tomorrow and there is no
urgent need for acceleration
no more urgent need for acceleration
than when it comes to the future of
our fragile planet
while much of the world's activity froze
during lockdowns and shutdowns
the planet continued to get dangerously
and we see it all around us
from houses evacuated due to the glacier
collapse on the mobile
to fires burning through oregon to crops
destroyed in romania by the most severe
droughts
in decades but we also
saw nature coming back into our lives
we longed for green spaces and clean air
for mental health and our physical
well-being
we know change is needed and we also
know it is possible the european green
deal is
our blueprint to make that
transformation
at the heart of it is our mission
to become the first climate neutral
continent
in 2050 but we will not get there with
the status quo
we need to go faster and we
need to do things better
we looked in depth in every sector
to see how fast we could go
and how to do it in a responsible
evidence-based way we held a wide public
consultation
and conducted an extensive impact
assessment
and on this basis the european
commission
is proposing to increase the 2030
targets for emission reduction
to at least 55 percent
i recognize that this increase from 40
to 55
is too much for some and not enough for
others
but our impact assessment clearly shows
that our economy and industry
can manage this and they want it
just yesterday 170 business leaders and
investors
from smes to some of the world's biggest
companies
wrote to me calling on europe to set a
target at least at 55
our impact assessment clearly shows that
meeting this target
would put the european union firmly on
track
for climate neutrality by 2050 and
for meeting our paris agreement
obligations
and if others follow our lead
the world will be able to keep warming
below 1.5
degrees celsius i'm fully aware that
many of our partners are far away from
that
but we have to lead and i will come back
to the carbon board adjustment mechanism
later
but for us the 2030 target is ambitious
it's achievable and it is beneficial for
europe
we can do it and we have already shown
that we can do it
while emissions dropped 25 since 1990
our economy grew more than sixty percent
the difference is now that we now have
the technology
we have way more expert expertise and we
have the investment
and we're already embarking towards a
circular economy
with carbon neutral production we want
to be leading in the world on that
we have more young people pushing for
change
we have more proof that what is good for
the climate
is good for business and is good for us
all
and we have a solemn promise to leave
no one behind in this transformation
without just transition fund
we will support the regions that have a
bigger and more costly change to make
we have it all now it's our
responsibility
to implement it and to make it happen
and i want you at my side and i invite
you for this endeavor
because we only can do it together this
is
our mission on the european level on
rebel members
meeting this new target will reduce our
energy
import dependency
will create millions of extra jobs
and more than half air pollution
pollution
to get there we have to start now
by next summer we will revise all of our
climate and energy legislation
to make it fit for 55
we will enhance emission trading boost
renewable energy
improve energy efficiency
reform energy taxation
but the mission of the european green
deal
involves much more than cutting
emissions
this is important but it is about making
systemic
modernization across our economy
society and industry it is about
building a stronger world to live in
our current levels of consumption of raw
material
energy water food and land use is
not sustainable we need to change how we
treat nature
how we produce and consume how we live
and work
eat and heat travel and transport
so we will tackle everything from
hazardous chemicals
to deforestation to pollution
this is a plan for a true recovery
it is an investment plan for europe and
this is where next generation
you will make a real difference
firstly 37
of next generation eu will be spent
directly
on our european green deal objectives
and it i will ensure that it also takes
green financing to the next level
we are world leaders in green finance
and we are the largest issuer of green
bonds worldwide
we are leading the way in developing a
reliable
eu green bond standard and i can
announce today
that we will set a target of 30
of next generation eu's 750 billion
euros
to be raised through green bonds
secondly next generation you should
invest in lighthouse european projects
with the biggest impact hydrogen
renovation
and one million electric charging points
and allow me to explain how this could
work
two weeks ago in sweden a unique
fossil-free
steel pilot began test operations
it will replace coal with hydrogen
to produce clean steel
this shows the potential of hydrogen
to support our industry with a new
with a clean license to operate
i want next generation eu to create new
european hydrogen valleys
to modernize our industries to power our
vehicles
and to bring new life to our rural areas
the second example are the buildings we
live and work in
our buildings generate more than 40
percent
of our emissions they need to become
less wasteful less expensive
and more sustainable and we know that
the construction sector can
even be turned from a carbon source
into a carbon sink if organic building
materials like wood and smart
technologies like ai
are being used so i want
next generation eu to kick-start
a european renovation wave and make our
union a leader
in the circular economy but this is not
just an
environmental or economic project
it needs to be a new cultural project
for europe
every movement has its own look and feel
and we need to give our systemic change
its own distinct aesthetics
to match style with sustainability
and this is why we will set up
a new european bauhaus
a co-creation space where architects
artists students engineers designers
work together to make that happen
this is next generation eu this is
shaping the world we want to live in a
world served by an economy that cuts
emission
boosts competitiveness reduces energy
poverty
creates rewarding jobs and improves
quality of life
a world where we use digital
technologies to build build a healthier
a greener society and this can only be
achieved
if we all do it together
and i will insist that recovery plans
don't just bring
us out of the crisis but also help us
propel
europe forward in the world of tomorrow
see you guys
that this pandemic occurs during a time
without digital technology
quarantine spent in full isolation cut
off from
family relatives supply problems
inability to go to work surely this is
what it must have looked like
100 years ago in the last pandemic
a century on modern technology
enables us in a time of severe pandemic
for young people to pursue their studies
at home
people to work from home keeping
production lines
open and distributing those products
it allows public administration to
provide important services
to citizens
in a matter of just a few weeks we
witnessed
greater progress and digital
transformation than
over several years but we are
coming up against the limit of what
analog technology will allow us to do
now
this transition has just begun
the forthcoming decade will and must be
europe's
digital decade we need a common plan
for a digital europe with clearly set
out targets and objectives
for 2050. we need targets for 2030
in the field of connectivity digital
competence
skills public administration and many
other areas
we also need clear principles the right
to privacy the right to
access freedom of expression
the free flow of data and cyber security
in order to achieve all this europe must
take a leadership role or else it will
be
following others who will setting be
setting the standards for us
this is why quick and decisive action is
needed so badly now
there are three areas that we i believe
must focus on
first of all
when it comes to personal like data
b2c business to consumer
europe was too slow and has had to
follow others
this must not happen again with
industrial data
and i have some good news europe is in
the lead in this field
we have the technology and we have the
industry
but this alone will not win us the race
the quantity of industrial data will
multiply four-fold over the next five
years
and that will bring with it
opportunities
so now is the time to allow businesses
startups smes to
fully exploit the potential industrial
data
is invaluable when it comes to
developing new products and new services
however the reality looks very different
eighty percent
of industrial data that are gathered and
collected
never get put to any use which is a
huge waste a true data economy
would be a powerful driver for inner
innovation however
this is why europe must secure
the data and make it widely accessible
we need common data
collection in the field of energy and
health care for example
which will boost the activity of
research clusters
businesses research centers must be able
to access in a secure way
this data and use its potential
this is why in the context of next
generation eu
we will be establishing a european cloud
on the basis of gaia x
the second area that we must focus on
is technology itself in particular
artificial intelligence now whether it's
for precision farming or precision
healthcare and early diagnosis
in healthcare or autonomous driving
ai opens up whole new worlds for us
it's truly fantastic but these worlds
need to be regulated too
algorithms must not create any black
boxes
and there must be clear rules and
procedures when things go wrong
the european commission will be
proposing a
new european law in this field
which will tackle the issue of
supervision of personal data and control
of personal data
every time we access a website and it
asks
us to establish a new digital identity
or set up a user
profile or to register on a platform
the fact is we simply don't know what
will happen to our data
we must put a stop to this
this is why the european commission will
come forward with
a proposal for a new secure
digital identity one that we can really
trust and that citizens can use
europe-wide
for everything whether it's right
renting a bicycle
or paying taxes an identity
that you have full control over where
you can control the data that is
transferred and how it is used
that is our idea of a
technology focused and centered around
people
for the service of people the third
focal point
infrastructure we must
keep up with the racing pace of
technology
and if we want
to build a europe that is on an equal
footing with others then we simply
cannot allow
40 percent of people in rural areas to
still
be lagging behind when it comes to
broadband access
broadband connections are
the foundation for home learning home
shopping
home office working and many of the
services that are now being offered
online
without broadband it's simply impossible
to run a business these days
or to expand a business
fast data connections are a basis a
requirement
and an opportunity for rural areas
to develop it's only with this
technology that rural areas will
fully be able to exploit their potential
and
attract investment and population
the investment leap that we're going to
see
through next generation eu is a one-time
opportunity
it's a once-in-a-lifetime opportunity to
move forward with development
in this field this is why we want to
focus on secure connectivity
developing 5g 6g and
fiberglass
we need to use this opportunity
to come up with a common approach
for connectivity and the development of
digital infrastructure in europe
now none of this is an end in itself
this is about no less than europe's
digital sovereignty
and in this context i'm very pleased to
announce
an 8 billion investment in
super computer technology this will be
high tech made in europe
european industry to be able to develop
its own driver for investment in
digital economy one that will allow us
to
use data in a way that is energy
efficient and secure
all this and more for me really is part
of this
digital europe honorable members
if we really press on the accelerated
pedal now we must
ensure that we remain dear to our
principle we allow that
retains control over its future sets the
course for its future we have everything
we need in order to realize this stream
industry is clamoring for a plan
and that plan is now in place there's
never been a better time to invest in
technology across europe from
sofia to lisbon
across the country continent we want to
open new digital clusters we have
the idea we have the investment power
to be truly successful in this field
which is why 20 of the next generation
eu budget will be earmarked for
digital development and with this we
hope to propel europe into the digital
age
on the basis of our values our strengths
and our ambitions
honorable members europe is determined
to use this transition
to build the world we want to live in
and that of course
extends well beyond our external borders
the pandemic has simultaneously shown
both the fragility of the global system
and the importance of cooperation to
tackle collective change
and in the face of the crisis some
around the world
choose to retreat into isolation
others actively destabilize the system
europe choose to reach out
our leadership is not about self-serving
propaganda
it is not about europe first
it is about being the first to seriously
answer the call when it is needed
in the pandemic european planes
delivering
thousands of tons of protective
equipment
landed everywhere from sudan to
afghanistan
somalia to venezuela we know
no of us will ever be safe until
all of us are safe and we know wherever
we live
whatever we have there has to be access
affordable
and safe access to vaccines treatments
and diagnostics
at the beginning of the pandemic there
was no funding there was no global
framework
for a covet 19 vaccine there was just
the rush
to be the first one to get one and this
was the moment when the european union
stepped up
to lead the global response with civil
society
with g20 with who and others
we brought more than 40 countries
together
to raise 16 billion euros
to finance research on vaccines on tests
on treatments for the whole world and
this
is europe's unmatched convening
power we can be so proud of
it is not enough to find a vaccine
we need to make sure that european
citizens and those around the world
have access to it and just this month
the european union joined the kovacs
global facility
and contributed 400 million euro
to help ensure that safe vaccines
are available not only for those who can
afford it
but for everyone who needs it because we
know vaccine nationalism
puts lives at risks only
vaccine cooperation saves lives
[Applause]
honourable members we are firm believers
in the strength and value of cooperating
in international bodies
it is with a strong united nation where
we can find long-term solutions
for crisis like libya and syria it is
with a strong world
health organization that we can better
prepare and respond
to global pandemics or local outbreaks
be it corona or abella
and it is with a strong world trade
organization
that we can ensure fair competition for
all
but the truth is also that the need
to revitalize and to reform the
multilateral system
has never been so urgent our global
system has grown
into a creeping paralysis
major powers are either pulling out
or they're taking the institutions
hostage for their own interests
and neither road will lead
anywhere yes we need change
but we need change by design and not
by destruction of our international
system
and this is why i want the european
union to lead reforms on w-h-o and w-t-o
so that they are fit for today's world
but we know that multilateral reforms
take time
and in the meantime the world will not
stop
without any doubt there's a clear need
for europe to take clear positions
and quick actions on global affairs
two days ago the latest eu
china leaders meeting took place
the relationship between the european
union and china
is simultaneously one of the most
strategically important and
one of the most challenging we have and
from the outset
we have said china is a negotiating
partner
an economic competitor and
a systemic rival
we have interest in common on issues
such as climate
change and china has shown it is willing
to engage
through a high level dialogue but we
expect also china
to live up to his commitments in the
paris agreement
and to lead by example
in the economic field there's still hard
work to do
on a fair market access for european
companies
reciprocity and over capacity
and we continue to have an unbalanced
trade and investment partnership
and there is no doubt that we promote
very different systems of governance
and society we believe
in the universal value of democracy
and the rights of the individual
europe is certainly not without issues
think for example of growing
anti-semitism
but criticism and opposition we discuss
them here
publicly criticism and opposition are
not
only accepted but they are legally
protected there is an open debate about
all these issues
so we must call out human rights abuses
whenever and wherever they occur
be it on hong kong or be it with the
uighurs
but what holds us back
why are even even simple statements on
eu values
delayed watered down or held hostage for
other motives
when member states say europe is
too slow i say
be courageous and finally move to
qualified majority voting
at least on human rights and sanctions
[Applause]
implementation
[Applause]
this house has called many times for
european magnitsky act
and i can announce that we will now come
forward with a proposal
we need to complete our toolbox
honourable members be it in hong kong
moscow or minsk
europe must take a clear and swift
position
and i want to say it loud and clear the
european union
is on the side of the people of belarus
we have all been moved by the immense
courage
of those peacefully gathering in the
independence square
or taking part in the fearless women's
march
the elections that brought them into the
streets were neither free
nor fair and the brutal response by the
government
ever since has been shameful
the people of belarus must be
free to decide their own future
for themselves they are not pieces
on someone else's chessboard
and to those that advocate closer ties
with russia
i say that the poisoning of alexey
navalny
with an advanced chemical agent is not
a one off we have seen the pattern in
georgia
in ukraine in syria and salisbury
and an election meddling around the
world
and this pattern is not changing
and no pipeline will change that
turkey is and will always be an
important neighbor
but while we are close together on the
map
the distance between us appears to be
growing
yes turkey is in a troubled neighborhood
and yes it is hosting millions of
refugees
for which we support them with
considerable funding
but none of this is justification for
attempts
to intimidate their neighbors
our member states cyprus and greece can
always count on europe's full solidarity
on protecting
their legitimate sovereignty rights
the escalation in the eastern
mediterranean is in our mutual interest
the return of exploratory vessels to
turkish posts in the past few days
is a positive step in this direction
this is
necessary to create the much needed
space for dialogue
refraining from unilateral actions
and resuming talks in good faith
is the only path forward
the only path to stability and lasting
solutions honourable members
as well as responding more assertively
to global events
europe must deepen and refine its
partnerships
with its friends and allies
and this starts with revitalizing our
most enduring partnerships
we might not always agree with recent
decisions of the white house
but we will always cherish the
transatlantic alliance
based on shared values and history and
an
unbreakable bond between our people
so whatever what may happen later this
year
we are ready to build a new
transatlantic agenda
to strengthen our bilateral partnership
be it on trade on tech or taxation
and we are ready to work together on
reforming the international system we
build together jointly with like-minded
partners
for our own interests and in the
interest of the common good
we need new beginnings with old
friends on both sides
of the atlantic and on both sides
of the channel the scenes in this very
room
when we held hands and saying goodbye
with old
lang syne spoke a thousand words
and they showed an affection for the
british people that will never
fade but with every day that passes
the chances for timely agreement do
start
to fade negotiations are always
difficult
and we are used to that and the
commission has the best and most
experienced negotiator michelle barnier
to navigate us through that but talks
have not
progressed as the we would have wished
and that leaves us
very little time as ever
as ever this house will be the first to
know
and it will be the one that has the last
say
and i can assure you we will continue to
update you
thoroughly just as we did with the
withdrawal agreement this withdrawal
agreement
took three years to negotiate
and we worked relentlessly on it line by
line
word by word and together we succeeded
and the result guarantees our citizens
rights
financial interests the integrity of the
single market
and crucially the good friday agreement
and the european
union and the uk jointly agreed
it was the best and only way for
ensuring peace on the island of ireland
and we will never backtrack on that and
this agreement has been ratified
by this house and by the house of
commons
it cannot be unilaterally changed
disregarded or disciplined this is a
matter of
law and trust and good faith
[Applause]
and that is not just me saying it
i remind you of the words of margaret
thatcher i quote
britain does not break treaties it would
be bad for britain
bad for relations with the rest of the
world and bad for any future treaty
on trade end of quote this was true then
and this is true today
trust is the foundation of any strong
partnership
and europe will always be ready to build
strong partnerships
with our closest neighbors this starts
with the western balkans
the decision six months ago to open
accession negotiations
with albania and north macedonia was
truly
historical indeed
the future of the whole region lies in
the european union
we share the same history we share the
same destiny
the western balkans are part of europe
and they are not
just a stop over on the silk road
we will soon present an economic
recovery package for the western balkans
focusing on a number of regional
investment initiatives
and we will be there for the eastern
partnership countries
and our partners in the southern
neighborhood to help create jobs
and kick start the economies
when i came into office i chose for the
very first trip outside
the european union to visit the african
union
and it was a natural choice it was a
natural choice and it was a very clear
message
because we are not just neighbors
but we are natural partners
three months later i returned with my
entire college
to set out the priorities for a new
strategy
with africa it is a partnership of
equals where both sides share
opportunities
and responsibilities africa will be a
key partner
in building the world we want to live in
whether it is on climate digital or
trade
honourable members we will continue to
believe in open and fair trade across
the world
not as an end in itself but as a way to
deliver prosperity at home and promote
values and standards more than
600 000 jobs in europe are tied for
example to the trade with japan
and our recent agreement with vietnam
alone helped secure historic
labor rights for millions of workers in
the country
we will use our diplomatic strength and
economic clout
to broker agreements that make a
difference
such as designating maritime protected
areas in the antarctica this would be
one of the biggest
acts of environmental protection in
history
we will form high ambition coalitions on
issues such as the digital ethics
of fighting deforestation
and we will develop partnerships with
all like-minded partners from
asian democracies to australia africa
the americas and anyone else who wants
to join
we will work on just globalization we
cannot
take this for granted
we must insist on fairness and a level
playing field
and europe will always move forward
alone or with partners
to do that
i want to come back to the carbon board
adjustment mechanism
carbon must have its price
because nature cannot pay this price
anymore
and this carbon board adjustment
mechanism should motivate
foreign producers and eu importers
to reduce their carbon emissions while
ensuring
that we level the playing field in a wto
compatible way
the same principle applies to digital
taxation
we will spare no effort to reach
agreement in the framework of oecd and
g20
but let there be no doubt should an
agreement fall
short of a fair tax system that provides
long-term sustainable revenues europe
will come forward
with a proposal early next year
i want europe to be a global advocate
for that
honourable members if europe is to play
a vital role in the world
it must also create new vitality
insight and to move forward we must now
overcome the differences
that held us back the historic agreement
on next generation eu shows that it can
be done
and the speed with which we took
decisions on fiscal rule state aid or
sure
all this shows it can be
done so let's do it
migration is an issue that has been
discussed
long enough migration has
always been effect for europe and it
will
always be throughout centuries
it has defined our societies
it has enriched our cultures and it has
shaped
many of our lives and this will always
be the case as we all know
the 2015 migration crisis caused many
deep divisions between member states
with some of those scars still healing
today
a lot has been done since but a lot
is still missing if we are all ready to
make
compromises without compromising on our
principles
we can find a solution
next week the commission will put
forward its pact on migration
we will take a human and humane approach
and there are principles
saving lives at sea
is not optional
and those countries who fulfill their
legal and moral duties
or are more exposed than others
must be able to rely on the solidarity
of our
whole european union
we will ensure a closer link between
asylum and return
we have to make a clear distinction
between those who have the right to stay
and those who do not we will take
action to fight smugglers strengthen
external borders
deepen external partnerships and create
legal pathways and we will make
sure that people who have the right to
stay
are integrated and made to feel
welcome they have a future to build
and skills energy and talent
i think of swat
the teenage syrian refugee who arrived
in europe dreaming of being a medical
doctor
within three years she was awarded a
prestigious scholarship
from the royal college of surgeons in
ireland
i think of the libyan and somalian
refugee doctors
who offered them medical skills the
moment the pandemic stuck
in france and last year i told you of
the story of muas
whom i had the honor to meet
he is studying physics today in europe
honorable members if we think about what
they
have overcome and what they have
achieved
then we simply must be able to manage
the question of migration together
the images of the morya camp are a
painful reminder
of the need for europe to come together
everybody has to take a step up here and
take responsibility and the commission
will just do that
the commission is now working on a plan
for joint pilot with the greek
authorities
for new camp on lesbos we can assist
with asylum and return
processes and significantly improve the
conditions for the refugees
but i want to be clear
if we step up then i
expect all member states to step
up too migration is a european
challenge and a whole of europe must do
its part
[Applause]
we must rebuild the trust among us and
move forward together
and this trust is at the very heart of
our union and the way we do
things together it is anchored
in our founding values our democracies
and in our community of
law as walter heinstein used to say
this is not an abstract term the rule of
law helps
protect people from the rule of the
powerful
it is the guarantor of our most basics
of everyday rights and freedoms
it allows us to give our opinion and to
be informed by a free
press before the end of the month
the commission will adopt the first
annual rule of law report
covering all member states it is a
preventive tool
for early detection of challenges
and for finding solutions
i want this to be a starting point for
commission
parliament and member states to ensure
there is no backsliding
the commission attaches the highest
importance
to the rule of law and this is why we
will ensure
that money from our budget a next
generation eu
is protected against any kind of fraud
corruption or conflict of interest this
is
[Applause]
non-negotiable
the last months have also reminded us
how fragile it can be
we have a duty to always be vigilant to
care and nurture
for the rule of law and breaches of the
rule of law
cannot be tolerated i will continue to
defend it
and the integrity of our european
institutions
be it about the primacy of european law
the freedom of the press the
independence of the judiciary
all the sale of golden passports
european values are not
for sale
donna remembers these values are more
important than ever
i say that because when i think of the
state of the union
i am reminded of the words of john hume
one of the great europeans who sadly
passed away this year
if so many people live in peace today
on the island of ireland it is in large
part because of
his unwavering belief in humanity and
conflict resolution
he used to say that
conflict was about difference
and that peace was about respect
for difference and as he so rightly
reminded this house in 1998 and i quote
the european visionaries decided
that difference is not a threat
difference is natural difference is the
essence of humanity end of quote
and these words are just as important
today as they
ever have been because when i look
around
we ask ourselves where
is the essence of humanity when three
children in wisconsin watch their father
shot by the police while they sit in the
car
where is the essence of humanity
when anti-semitic carnival costumes
openly parade on our streets
where is the essence of humanity
when every single day roma people
are excluded from society
and others held back simply because of
the color of their skin
or their religious belief
i am proud to live in europe in this
open society
of values and diversity but even here in
this union
these stories are daily reality for so
many people
and this reminds us that progress on
fighting racism and
hate is fragile it is hard
won but very easily lost
so now is the moment to make change to
build a truly anti-racist
union that goes from condemnation
to action and the commission is putting
forward an action play
plan to start making that happen
as part of this we will propose
to extend the list of eu crimes
to all forms of hate crime
and hate speech whether because of race
religion gender or sexuality hate is
hate and no one should have to put up
with that
[Applause]
we will strengthen our racial inequality
laws where there are gaps
we will use our budget to address
discrimination in era such as employment
housing or health care we will get
tougher on enforcement when
implementation
lags behind because in this human union
fighting racism will never be
optional we will improve education and
knowledge on the historical cultural
causes of racism
we will tackle unconscious bias that
exists
in people in institutions well yes and
even
algorithms and we will appoint the
commission's first
ever anti-rise racism coordinator
to keep this at the top of our agenda
and to work directly with people
civil society and institutions
honorable members
i will not rest when it comes to
building a union
of equality a union
where you can be who you are
and love who you want without fear
and recrimination
because being yourself is
not your ideology
it is your identity and
no one can ever take it away so i want
to be crystal clear
lgbtqi free zones
are humanity free zones and they have
no place in our union
[Applause]
and to make sure that we support the
whole community
the commission will soon put forward a
strategy to strengthen lgbtqi
rights as part of this
i will also push for mutual recognition
of family relations in the eu because
if you are a parent in one country
you are of course a parent in every
country
and adversity world where we work
together
to overcome our differences and
when we support each other in the
difficult times
we are talking about a world of tomorrow
that is
stronger more respectful more healthy
a world that we are building to leave to
our children
we are teaching our children how to live
they are teaching us what life means
this year has showed that
more than ever
there are millions of young people who
are
calling on us to enact change for a
healthier planet
or the hundreds of thousands of children
who put up beautiful rainbows
in their windows as a sign of solidarity
all across
europe there is one image though that
has
really stayed with me over these last
six months
it is an image which shows us the world
through the eyes of our children that is
the image of karola
and victoria two
young girls who were playing tennis
on the roofs of liguria in italy
during the lockdown
it was not just their courage and their
talent that shone through in this image
but it is also the lesson
that they can teach us it is
a lesson to never give up
when faced with obstacles that you
should never
let conventions hold you back and that
you should always seize the moment
that is what karola vittoria and all the
young people of europe
teach us every day about how to live
this is the future generation of
europeans next generation
eu this year europe
has taken up their example and made
a step forward together when we needed
to find a way forward for our future we
did not let outdated conventions
hold us back when we
felt a fragility around us we seized the
moment to give
fresh impetus to our union
when we had the opportunity to
go it alone as we have done in the past
we chose to use the full strength of the
27
to give all 27 a chance
for the future we have shown
that we are in this together and that we
will
overcome this together ladies and
gentlemen members of parliament
the future will be what we make of it
and europe will be what we want it to be
we should stop trying to break it down
and instead build it up to make it
stronger and to build the world
that we want to live in long live europe
you're with dw news live from berlin
you're getting live coverage right now
from brussels where in a wide-ranging
speech hitting on numerous
internal and global issues eu commission
president
ursula fonda lion has delivered her
first state of the union speech
recapping some main points for you now
the president touched on the need for
the bloc to prepare for future health
crises like the coronavirus pandemic she
also highlighted the need for
economic stability in the wake of the
crisis urging members to
deepen the eu monetary union while also
calling for continuing labor reforms
on the climate fun lions said the eu
needed to go faster to
achieve climate goals and proposed
raising carbon emission reduction
targets
significantly she also touched on plans
to invest in digitalization
and ai with the creation of a new eu
superpower a super computer rather fun
line also touted a new eu migration pack
due to be unveiled
next week okay let's go
to brussels live now for more from dws
bureau chief
there alexandra of fundament alexandra a
wide-ranging speech there european
commission president said
she wants to move the eu from fragility
to
vitality what what struck you most about
her path
to get there
well i think what was very interesting
was to see how she really managed to
to send a positive message how she was
trying to convince the members of
the european parliament that the
european union
can and should emerge stronger more
resilient
out of the corona pandemic crisis
and how she was insisting that the
european union
should take a leadership role in terms
of
climate change with regards to the
climate change
where she announced that the commission
is proposing to increase
the target of emissions reduction
up to 55 in 2030
and she also was saying that the
european union now
after this this crisis or in the middle
of this crisis
has a chance to be a leader with regards
regard to
digital transformation and she made
quite a huge number of very concrete
proposals
one of them the establishment of a
secure digital identity that the eu
citizens could use
whether we are talking about riding a
bicycle off or paying taxes
okay there was also some very specific
uh suggestions there from her
from also getting to a global vaccine
to fight the pandemic and moving into
the future for potentially other
vaccines as well what did she have to
say there
well she was once again talking
important is to coordinate
the efforts and what i found very
interesting maybe not
surprising but very telling is that uh
talking about uh what is important for
europe
and how europe uh is standing for
solidarity she also mentioned the white
house and
the pr the u.s president and and
his america first policy uh without
mentioning his name she said that europe
is not
about putting europe first that
europe is for standing for all nations
working together to overcome
this coronavirus pandemic but she was
also criticizing the us by saying that
there are major forces
that are pulling out of international
institutions that are taking those
into institutions um hostage uh
at times where we need we have to work
together and to strengthen international
institutions
for example like the wmho
the commission president uh also touched
on some of the challenges
of facing the european union right now
right now some
old wounds from the migration crisis uh
for example there's still
healing
well that it's true um ozola fonda lion
talked
about uh the refugee crisis she talked
about the situation
on the greek island of lesbos what's
going on
in morya and here once again
she stressed how important it is to uh
show solidarity with those who need
refuge
but at the same time how important it is
for the european uh
mem states to to be to be together to
come together
on this issue and and to work together
to
solve this uh crisis alexander
phenomenon in brussels live where
ursula fonda line has just delivered her
first state of the union
address thanks very much for now
alexandra
and with me here in the studio richard
walker our chief international editor
richard a lot on the plate here just
went far longer than we expected she
said
she wasn't going to details but we have
plenty of them uh ursula on the line
saying it's all about european values
strengths and ambitions
you know broadly where did she want to
take the european union
yeah i mean it was striking wasn't it we
were we started to look at the clock
here at close to the hour mark and i
think she hit one hour and 17 minutes at
the end which
three languages even rivals some of the
longest u.s state of the union speeches
um but i think i would agree with
alexandra what she just said at the
beginning there about trying to present
um you know a positive message while at
the beginning of the speech she
acknowledged
the kind of trauma that europe has been
going through and is still going through
and the anxiety that the people
feel i think you know a big part of her
speech was about projecting confidence
i think a key line that she made early
on in this speech that
she's saying that this is now the moment
to make change happen by design
not by disaster or by dictat from others
so this is like a kind of declaration of
okay we've got so far
so far so good we've had some big
problems but we're kind of
we feel like we're fairly on top of the
pandemic at the moment
we need to be thinking about the future
uh and also need to be kind of
marrying what uh europe has learned from
the pandemic
uh to the commitments that they already
had and i think maybe the kind of
overarching theme that you could say
on that front was well-being uh mental
health she also mentioned
physical health economic health way
beyond that well being
in the health area well-being in society
and the economy and well-being for the
planet
um and i think that was kind of the
thread uh thro uh
flowing through her speech because i
went through the whole speech didn't
absolutely yeah
it certainly did let's take a listen now
to that uh to a fun line
on the issue of the chronovirus and and
how to deal
with the pandemic so for me it is
crystal clear
we need to build a stronger european
health union it is time to do that
and to start making this a reality we
must now draw the first lessons from the
health crisis
we need to make our new e4 eu for health
program
future proof and this is why i had
proposed to increase
funding and i'm grateful that this
parliament
is ready to fight for more funding
and remedy the cuts made by the european
council
a future proof health plan how does she
want to get there
that is a very ambitious goal well i
think that that's going to be the
question that we pose at almost every
step along this speech you know you have
your theme of well-being but
okay how do you achieve it um it was
interesting how she talked about this
because she she
she talked back about the early stages
of the crisis and i think many people
will remember and
in the first few weeks or a couple of
months of the crisis
there was a lot of controversy in europe
that countries were going their own way
they were doing their own thing they
were closing their borders they were
looking they were holding on to their
own kind of protective gear all of that
ppe that the health systems needed
um fond de line kind of talked about the
moment where europe really tried to get
back on top of that but she said that
she achieved that and the european union
achieved that despite
not having the powers to do so and that
now is the time to start saying all
right
the eu needs to have central powers uh
relating to this health area and there
are some things which were quite
specific like saying
that she wants to strengthen bodies like
the ecdc that's the european center for
disease control so more centralization
and
to address issues like uh there were
inadequate stockpiles
that's right strategic strategic
stockpiles
and a global health summit i found that
a very interesting
um initiative yeah that's something that
she wants to hold in italy next year she
said that she's spoken to the italian
government italy because italy will be
uh chairing the g20 so the international
grouping
next year but whenever in the european
union you get to a discussion about
where the powers are held are they held
by nation states or are they held
centrally
uh by the european union that is
inevitably a huge discussion
people don't like giving up powers it's
going to be very difficult moving
forward with this i mean there's going
to be a lot of discussion
uh necessary at the parliamentary level
in strasbourg where this was in brussels
but at the commission as well
how do you think her proposals are going
to go down on the labor front i mean it
sounded great
you know a minimum wage for everyone but
couldn't that be disruptive economically
in the european union where jobs flow to
certain regions specifically because
the labor rates are lower yeah well it
was interesting that she wasn't calling
for
a statutory for a legal minimum wage in
every country she said that she's also
that
she said that she's particularly a fan
of collective bargaining
and bear in mind she's a conservative i
mean this sounds like kind of social
democratic question she's from
michael's cdu party we have to remember
that yeah so she's a conservative she's
not saying that this has to come
come via kind of legal measures um but
she's saying that she wants to see that
across the eu
but again of course this is now up to
individual countries whether they
implement that but
you know i think there she's using the
bully pulpit effectively saying
um that you know the pandemic
as a whole has proven how successful
the european kind of social market
economy which caused a german term but
she applied that kind of more broadly to
europe
can be and that the implicit criticism
was of the united states
there were a number of implicit
criticisms in the united states
alexandra
yes but but essentially saying look what
happened i mean she didn't say this
spell this out but implicitly look what
happened in the united states
this incredibly precipitous uh uh
fall in employment like
eight-digit numbers of people suddenly
uh uh
uh getting unemployment benefit that
that has not really happened in the eu
because of
this short-time working scheme that was
brought in on eu level so
essentially that the eu would would
support going on to kind of cutting
workers hours and
subsidizing that to the companies and
hailing that as a big success of
european solidarity in this crisis
there was another uh success that that
uh ursula funda line is looking at
moving forward she wants to make the eu
the leader in climate change
the battle against climate change and
meeting carbon reduction goals etc
let's take a listen to what the
commission president had to say on that
we need to go faster and we
need to do things better
we looked in depth in every sector
to see how fast we could go
and how to do it in a responsible
evidence-based way the european
commission
is proposing to increase the 2030
targets for emission reduction
to at least 55 percent
okay that is a big change going from 40
to 55
by the end of the decade germany's going
to have to lead on that certainly
yeah well i mean but she pointed out
that only very recently she had received
a letter from
more than 100 businesses calling for
this level of ambition so she's
she's really framing this is not
something that's anti-business or
difficult
uh necessarily but also a huge
opportunity but i think here
there were some quite interesting
specifics for instance talking about how
again coming back to this idea of kind
of marrying
getting out of the pandemic and
recovering from the pandemic to these
long-term
goals so trying to bring together this
recovery fund
with these green targets and she says
that she wants
37 of the spending from the european
green
from the recovery fund to be on green
deal
goals and even using green bonds
as an investment mechanism uh to achieve
that so
quite interesting specifics there and
it'll be interesting to see what kind of
take up like these green
bonds get and that goes the green bonds
are going to be a big
a big question moving forward richard
thanks very much for coming in on this
our international chief international
editor
richard walker